and for our final rule tonight it's time
for another edition of one of our
favorite departments here on real time
explaining jokes to idiots
whereas the public service i break down
jokes for the humor impaired
not that i have anyone particular in
mind
[Applause]
now i know we're all sick of talking
about the slap but i'm sorry one more
thing needs to be said
comedians
have been under attack for quite some
time and i need to stick up for my tribe
this war on jokes must end
so tonight let's zapruda film this thing
once and for all and explain
jokes to idiots
[Applause]
now at the oscars chris rock came out to
present a boring award and first did
what he is supposed to do get some
laughs during what we comics call crowd
work
[Laughter]
denzel and javier bardem each got
spritzed
and then chris made what in the business
is known as a some [ __ ] is like some
other [ __ ] joke
he said to jada smith jada can't wait
for g.i jane 2. we're
recalling the late 90s movie starring
demi moore
that's it
that's the joke you remind me of some
other beautiful buzz-cutted movie star
it wasn't an alopecia joke any more than
the one about the chicken crossing the
road is about bird flu
not an insult although insult humor
is also a staple of comedy and in fact
an example of insulting someone's looks
was on display that night when regina
hall said we've been dealing with coed
for two years it's been really hard on
people and amy schumer said yeah just
look at timothy chalamet and they cut to
j.k simmons
[Applause]
who made a face a lot like the one jada
would make later on
but that's where it ended it's called
being a good sport especially when
you're a rich celebrity
let the common people take the piss out
of you for one stinking minute
and importantly chris's joke was
received as funny
as evidenced by the audience and will
smith laughing
[Music]
and this is the moment where we got to
see a live-action real-time
encapsulation of how cancel culture
works look at what happens next jada
shoots her husband a look let's slow the
tape down to capture this moment
there
[Applause]
back and to the left
back and to the left
back and to the left
[Applause]
before this moment will is laughing
because he hasn't yet found out
that his original genuine reaction is
wrong and that he should conform
[Applause]
to a different view
and he's the one who's being manly
i've seen the same syndrome happen in
comedy clubs woke hecklers who literally
have to wait for the laughter to die
down before they yell that's not funny
this war on jokes must end will smith
didn't get kicked out of the oscars for
going ike turner on chris but kevin hart
got kicked out of hosting it
for a joke who are these people who say
cancel culture isn't a real thing just
among comedians who've gotten fired and
lost gigs for exercising their freedom
of expression the toll is high
gilbert godfried and kathy griffin were
tasteless so what that's why we like
them
comedians are the ones testing where the
line is we can't always be perfect any
more than tom brady will never throw an
interception
dave chappelle lost distribution for his
documentary and sarah silverman was
fired from a film over an old sketch
where she wore blackface to make fun of
racism
roseanne lost the tv show she created
with her name on it over tweets that
were very offensive but not at all clear
roseanne knew them to be she is crazy
and i say that as a friend
all comedians are a little crazy and you
need crazy on that wall
will smith wasn't pulled off stage but
comedian nemesh patel was literally
pulled off stage during a performance at
columbia for a joke
about how hard it is to be gay and black
not an anti-gay joke mind you a pro-gay
joke
but one of the event organizers walked
on stage and said i don't think you're
entitled to certain jokes you're making
well a sense of entitlement certainly is
a big part of the problem here but not
on the part of the comedian
[Applause]
and that's the thing the people who
can't take a joke now aren't old ladies
in the bible belt
they're gen z at elite colleges
where comedy goes to die
kids used to go to college and lose
their virginity now they go to lose
their sense of humor
vice recently interviewed college
bookers who revealed that before a
comedian even takes the stage they're
asked to edit out anything from their
act that may cause offense
leaving a world where more and more
topics are off limits and soon there'll
be nothing left to joke about except
airline food and starbucks getting your
name wrong
judd apatow has an awesome new
documentary coming here to hbo about
george carlin owner of the most famous
180 in comedy history when he turned his
back on a lucrative career in nightclubs
in order to let his hair down and be
himself in front of a younger crowd who
welcomed irreverence
in 1970 george said i got to go to
colleges i belong with people who are
open and will let me be myself an
experiment
oh george
it's a good thing you're dead
because today
the seven words you can't say on tv or
jada can't wait for g.i jane too
for all those who are constantly
demanding an apology for jokes
maybe it's you who should apologize to
us
for all the great jokes that we never
got to hear
the brilliant thoughts that were never
uttered those are the invisible scars of
cancel culture let's have a moment of
silence for that and a spot in the in
memoriam package
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for all the viable jokes that could have
lived but were aborted
because a voice in someone's head said
are you sure you want to risk saying
that
that's self-censorship the worst kind of
all
but you will get none of that on my new
hbo special
it's called adulting
and it premieres in this time slot a
week from tonight as the kids say it's
fire
you